so first they told you critical race
theory wasn't a real thing now the
radical left is doing what they do best
they're moving the goalposts ever so
slightly now critical race theory is a
thing but white people are just too
stupid to understand it it was education
right which is code for
white parents don't like the idea of
teaching about race some of it was
uh dog whistle racism this is about the
fact that a good chunk of voters out
there are okay with white supremacy
let's call a thing a thing actually
scratch that they are more than okay
they believe it joining me now for
reaction is the host of just listen to
yourself podcast kiera davis alongside
the hill media columnist joe concha uh
kyra just take it away just just go for
it yeah i can't i don't even know what
to say these people are they they're
parodies of themselves now i mean don't
even get me started on joy trying to
tell us that education is code for white
supremacy this is a this is a a misnomer
this is a a prejudice that we've been
battling in the black community forever
forever we've been told that educated
black people are trying to be white so
joy now here comes joy reid come along
trying to tell us that being educated is
code
for being white
you know you know what joy keep
pretending keep pretending that black
parents like me don't care about my
child's education and i don't have a
stake in it and people like me aren't
going to the ballot box that it's only
white people you keep pretending because
what's going to happen is black people
are going to pull up chalks and roll
right on out of the democrat party they
are quickly coming to
the place where they're not going to be
able to depend on the black vote to save
them very much longer if they're going
to keep up this ridiculous attitude
parents everywhere care about education
for their kids it's not education isn't
a white issue joy reid i mean it's just
it's offensive you know she's kyra is so
right joe
have they looked at the latest
homeschool numbers for black folks
they're pulling the kids out
and it's not because of crts but it's
because their kids aren't getting a
quality education because they would
prefer to spend time on that instead of
math reading you know things that
actually we need to go to the next level
joe
math reading writing science we're
currently we the united states are
ranked 25th in the world lawrence in
that those categories china is number
one of course so yeah that's why you're
seeing those numbers go up but this is a
craptastic combination of being blind
and tone deaf here uh on the part of the
joyrides and sunny hostans of the world
who only get to be on national
television because they play the race
card from the bottom of the deck and
they further divide the country in the
process wow what a strategy attack
parents who simply want to say in what
their kids are taught and not only
criticize those tax paying parents for
acting like you know parents but call
them white supremacists in the process
wow wisteria lane has changed because
white supremacists voted for winsome
sears the first black female to win
election statewide in virginia because
glenn younkin captured more than 50
percent of the latino vote last week
lawrence latinos support white supremacy
wow who knew yeah because
years is challenged go ahead the
identity didn't matter i mean they make
it when you start attacking people's
kids the foundation of a lot of parents
lives is their kids these people
weren't involved with politics these
were democrats they were these were
independents these were people by the
way they still classified themselves as
democrats but said this election we've
had enough but there's something deeper
that's happened i want to get you guys
reaction to what this msnbc contributor
had to say uh earlier take a look
what the democrats theory of the case is
is that the white non-non-college
educated voter cares about things like
kitchen table issues like infrastructure
and pipes and how many gallons of milk
you can put on the table
i contend that what they care about is
using their guns on black people and
getting away with it that's what they
want that's what they actually are in it
for
this
this is insane here like they they they
can't believe it they can't
we we've just we live in the upside down
i mean i i can't even believe that this
is what in what passes for intelligent
discourse right now you've just accused
you know uh millions of people in this
country of of waking up every morning
with no other desire not to feed their
kids not to pay their bills not to go to
work or go visit their mom in the
nursing home no no other desire than to
go out and murder black people you know
if you want to ask
why is this country so divided gosh
lawrence why is everything so political
these idiots make everything political
they can't accept that people like me go
to the ballot box and vote the way we
want to vote and it's such a lie kira i
don't know about that black family my
black family's from texas we stay
strapped we're always ready with our gun
i don't i don't know joe
i don't know either and i won't even say
that person's name that that just
appeared uh this is the same person
he's one of the founding fathers in
media on defunding the police and he
portrays himself as a spokesperson for
the black community yet you talk to an
overwhelming number of blacks they are
against defunding the police gallup has
something like eight and ten are against
that because they know that such a move
would impact minority communities the
most negatively the most fatally and
look i'm all for free speech but there
is a line and the line here has been
eviscerated come on saying white people
care more about that black people i mean
let me finish here lawrence because the
powers that be at comcast who own mbc
and msnbc should step in and say take
this person off the air he's toxic his
rhetoric is well past provocative it's
reckless it's beneath even our low
standards that's never going to happen
because that would take some backbone
and the people that run that network are
jellyfish for allowing a clown like that
on the air saying something like that
and the people that run that network are
white
you know all of the people that run
these shows that guys like this go on
and and jabber about they're white all
these people work for white people white
folks sign their paychecks white folks
teach their kids live right next door to
them so how dare they it's lazy lazy
it's divisive it's not helping the
country but i don't think they want to
help the country anyway kyra joe thanks
so much for coming on hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else